so basically she's saying that a woman
should not be able to decide to
terminate a child
oh I see I didn't say that
I didn't say that no no no no no no no I
found some traditional Catholics oh some
traditional Catholics and they'll tell
you about birth control you want to get
pregnant you have sex otherwise you know
when you're when you're ovulating and
you work around it because proper
Catholics don't believe in child con
birth control oh I see and um my son's
my my my late stepdad
his former partner was Catholic they
have 13 children so every time they were
going to have sex they knew that if we
have it at this time or there's a
possibility because they in those days I
didn't know about ovulating you're going
to get pregnant so if every woman and
every man went out there especially the
women because they're the ones that have
to carry the baby if you knew that every
time you had sex there's a possibility
you got pregnant they be left sex sound
as an atheist he doesn't want kids
as an atheist who don't want kids I just
can't have sex or just have to work
around what I'm going to be ovulating
yes if I have no more periods that be
well you can just work your way around
it
[Music]
also because I am pro-life and I don't
want that would just lead to whatever
that would lead to a massive spike in
abortions and I think that would be okay
there's more abortions
are there more abortions after the
development of birth control than before
I think we're talking about things in an
Ideal World I think we're forgetting on
this self-determination you can say to
someone you shouldn't do that that is
naive as well I just say as a parent
you're going don't go out and do drugs
and have sex they're going to do it
anyway and that's what we're like a
society we're gonna go out and have sex
we're going to do it with you the
difference is with birth control you
take away the consequence and I just
think there's ramifications when you
take away the consequence if you look at
after the development of birth control
like the chart
um of when birth control was introduced
and then the divorce rate in society
it's like literally the same if we take
away birth control wouldn't what would
happen to the abortion rates exactly I
think women would be I think women would
just be more careful with who they slept
with but that's that's the pressure on
the women
you don't okay
okay okay okay okay
you don't you don't you don't think it's
good that women should be careful with
who we sleep with yes
right right so because you said it's too
much pressure it's too much pressure to
like oh my gosh like I can't feel like
yeah I can't have sex
with your husband guys can we understand
how women get horny exactly
are you guys are okay with that concept
you know like I am horny outside of my
ovulation piece of women women have got
home
I'm gonna get horny before birth control
so you shouldn't have sex no no no no no
I'm saying
I think it goes back to what zooby said
to not sleep with someone where it's
horrible if you have a child with them
of course
definitely so bad right so you said it's
too much pressure like people used to
get like pregnant back in the day before
birth control they just have a shotgun
wedding and figure it out yeah because
it wasn't the end of it the problem is
that that that that that cow that cat is
out the bag now
right so in the past in a much more
traditional and a much more religious
Society
the answer to a you know
premarital pregnancy simple answer get
married and that's still that's still a
good answer for a lot of people as far
as I'm concerned however with the way
that marriage has changed there have
been too many changes to then go and go
okay let's ban birth control now and
you've already let all these other cats
out the back to me that's just that's
just chaos I just want to see what
happens I I feel like girls would make
better decisions if there was a
consequence I don't I think you just get
a huge spike in abortions yeah I don't
think you'd get a gigantic Spike no no
we should ban that too let's ban both
okay then that's different I'm much more
in favor
I don't I don't think that I know I
think that because that that out would
still exists so what would realistically
happen is people would still just go
around and prosecute their sex or
whatever so
[Laughter]
I would
do jail time
I put them in the stocks you know what
they had in their hands dude people
throwing Tomatoes
I do get what you mean by what you're
saying I think there has to be
consequences I think women I made a
comment down on this post and I got a
little backlash about I don't think it's
difficult to not get pregnant yes you're
correct yeah you're great I've never
found it difficult don't get pregnant
I've never been pregnant because I've
taken my birth control yes
um but yeah I think that in an Ideal
World birth control wouldn't need to
exist but wishes wouldn't need to exist
I am pro-abortion but
point being we're not in an Ideal World
we're in a society of people that have
free will self-determinations their own
environments they will never conform to
those things it will not stop it
happening people want to have sex let's
try the time let's try a bunch of horny
people in this world and they're not
going to stop [ __ ] because abortion
and and the like is is you know banned
okay I just I I feel like when people
like Thomas Soule always talks about it
like when people face the consequences
of their decisions they make better
decisions yeah generally generally
speaking but as we let's try it
as we can see this is just often not the
not the case though right as we were
talking about people having you know
dozens yeah exactly
yeah but there are a lot of times
they're incentivized to do so yeah like
because like Nick Cannon all those girls
are taken care of yeah yeah so so it's
not like a con they didn't get a
consequence they got a payout yeah yeah
people are generally going to do what
they're what their incentive advice to
do you know and I think one of the big
problems we have in in modern Western
Society is that on a lot of different
issues on a lot of things the incentives
are just broken right bad activities are
incentivized and good positive wholesome
things are often disincentivized or
sometimes even punished
um and I I don't I don't think it's good
I think you know long term that's going
to cause that's going to cause a lot of
chaos and these things are generational
and the more millions of children you
have growing up in certain circumstances
and modeling certain behaviors it's just
going to get exponentially worse
um with each generation so you know I'm
just big I'm big I'm very big on
personal responsibility and
accountability and I think it's much
better to make good decisions
up front rather than you know mess up in
all these very consequential ways and
then now you've Downstream now the line
we know everyone everyone has to clean
up the mess you know it's not just an
individual because we all Impact our
societies that we live in
that's my thought I stand by it bam
birth control abortion do you know what
I can take later right to vote
I actually think men are more like
irresponsible when it comes to
reproduction so I actually think it
should be the other way right more
irresponsible yeah they're more
irresponsible women are more responsible
30 of women that have had abortion no 40
of women that have had abortions have
had two or more come on yeah but they're
more men that have a lot of baby mamas
no they're not yes they are no 40 only
40 of men have even reproduced
historically
so throughout history most men like
getting to reproduce was a privilege
like women aren't most men aren't even
having sex like one out of three men
under 30 are virgins
one out of one out of three men under 30
or either virgins or haven't had sex in
the past year
all right
so that's not true is these stats in
America yeah there's no it's here too
it's in the west every single there's no
because no but this is right no it's
it's okay it's because three men under
30. there's a whole there's a whole
group of men you guys just don't see
because you guys are pretty girls and so
you're not gonna notice the guy that's
like working at Tesco involuntary
celibacy does not exist for women as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible